at the 100th anniversary of the chinese
communist party in 2021 chinese
president xi jinping outlined his vision
for the chinese dream we will achieve
the goal of building a great modern
socialist country all respect and
fulfill the tiny stream of national
rejuvenation
the fact that china and xi jinping talk
about a china dream really reminds us
the great powers need to have grand
narratives in the same way that the
united states had a narrative about the
american dream
[Music]
to make that china dream a reality and
achieve the great rejuvenation
chinese leaders believe they must have
the world's most powerful military a
strong country must have a strong
military
as only then can it guarantee the
security of the nation
the party came to recognize the
irrefutable truth that it must build a
people's military of its own
[Music]
china's military power has been growing
at an incredible speed over the last 20
years
in terms of sphere of influence we
absolutely know that china wants to be
dominant in asia so there is a target to
get to that point to be a military that
is appear to the greatest militaries in
the world by 2035.
the competition for influence is a
global one and through a multi-decade
trajectory fueled by planning money and
pragmatism china is building a military
that allows it to shape the 21st century
just as the u.s shaped the 20th
[Music]
[Music]
the most interesting question when it
comes to china's growth and what spurred
the growth is actually you don't have to
look back 50 years 40 years 30 years
actually most of these changes have
happened in the past 25 years
so if you go 25 years ago the chinese
economy was smaller than france's
economy they took up three percent of
global gdp
they had a military that you could
hardly even call it a military right a
navy that couldn't sail beyond the coast
until second half of 1990s
the chinese defense budget was
absolutely negligible at some points
less than 15 billion dollars
2.5 million troops
but now china is either the second or
third most powerful military in the
world
and it's got there largely as as always
through spending a lot of money
thanks to a 740 increase in military
spending as well as elite focus they've
now built one of the most formidable
militaries that this world has ever seen
china's defense expenditures have
multiplied by 12 times since 2000
and while america's military budget is
nearly four times that of china's it
does not mean that the us's military is
four times as powerful and that's
because of different objectives the
united states is trying to project power
all around the world that is extremely
costly
the u.s spends huge amounts of money on
the global war for tarot and the middle
east in the past two decades and of
course china lowers the defense
construction cost and it has cheaper
manpower
that budget of the united states it's
used for the united states to act as the
global guardian of the liberal
international order
instead the smaller budget of china is
mostly concentrated in one region we
have hundreds of bases overseas china
has one so they're really promoting
their military power regionally and so
that's one way that they can outcompete
the united states
i have been very very straightforward
and blunt with president putin
we will impose the most severe sanctions
that have ever been imposed economic
sanctions
when the us is distracted elsewhere
whether
it's over the ukraine issue now or the
war on terror for two decades beforehand
the united states cannot compete with
china countries like the us the uk
australia european countries overlook
the understanding of china's strategic
culture
and we didn't want to accept the fact
that while we were trading with china
china was growing militarily
to understand the magnitude of china's
determination in achieving its national
goals look no further than the belt and
road initiative china's trillion-dollar
global infrastructure plan and the
centerpiece of president xi jinping's
foreign policy the belton road
initiative is one of the big chinese
economic plans to build power and
influence in the world the united states
could have done 10 of those right but
instead we fought the war in afghanistan
and while the u.s and the eu are busy
policing the world
china has focused on building
infrastructure and when it comes to the
military it has had the same laser focus
the chinese were actually extremely
pragmatic in deciding you know how to go
about matching its military capacities
and increasing them so that it could
challenge us dominance and they did so
basically with weapons that are much
cheaper to produce than the things that
they destroy
[Music]
of course there are certain narrow areas
where chinese are more advanced these
areas include the hypersonic missiles
what we saw was a very significant event
of a test of a hypersonic weapon system
and it is very concerning i think i saw
in some of the newspapers they they used
the term sputnik moment
what they're really the us is really
saying is that these hypersonic missiles
could change the game
china is investing in hypersonic
missiles
principally to show the rest of the
world that is capable of developing
cutting-edge military technology because
of the name people focus the hypersonic
part on how fast they go but actually
the biggest issue when it comes to
defenses is that they can fly very low
because of the circular nature of the
earth if you have a radar system you
don't see it until close to the last
minute which makes it difficult to
intercept the broader strategic issue
that china is more advanced in this area
than the united states is brings up a
lot of anxiety about how the united
states technologically is falling behind
[Music]
they shown this on parrot in 2019 and
the americans are only expected to have
a first battery of similar missiles for
testing in 2023 so that's incredibly
that's an incredible like lead
and while the u.s is trailing china in
hypersonic technology china is quickly
closing the gap when it comes to naval
forces in 2015 china published a white
paper on china's military strategy
where the chinese elites stated that
china needs to move beyond an
old-fashioned traditional mentality
based on land power
the americans understand that the
chinese are gradually winning the arms
race they are simply building more ships
than the american can
the americans have been losing their
manufacturing for generations
the best example is shipbuilding
china is the country with the biggest
commercial shipbuilding industry in the
world china basically builds 40
of the ships in the world the us and its
european allies build about one percent
it allows the chinese to produce ships
at an extraordinary rate and to overtake
or to match the us you know very quickly
if they wish to
once you get into wartime those
advantages they really determined the
ability of the us to win the first and
second world wars for the allies
operating day and night on a 24-hour
mass production schedule
america giving wings to the greatest
armada of fighting ships the world has
ever known
many analysts nowadays believe that
china is already capable of winning a
short-term conflict within the first
island chain
[Music]
which is this line that goes from the
south of japan
through taiwan down to the philippines
and the south china sea
[Music]
in addition to a state-of-the-art navy
as well as their hypersonic missiles
china may also have an edge when it
comes to how wars are fought in the 21st
century
one of the most worrying areas of
chinese development has been cyber
warfare
as much as we know the chinese have the
biggest
cyber forces in the world
it's important to understand that the
chinese started to prioritize cyber
warfare and information warfare in
general very early in 1990s
they understood that the key of american
advantage was the information advantage
and to win they needed to
destroy this american advantage
they've been able to accelerate their
arms development programs by
gaining intelligence on u.s weapon
systems
with cyber
nobody's ever quite sure about what the
other side's capability is until it's
been used and once it's been used it's
gone and you have to develop something
else because it can be dealt with once
it's known
cyber immediately takes you on to the
question of artificial intelligence
and uh vladimir putin you know famously
said you know whoever wins that
competition will rule the world
and the idea is that once you develop ai
they can you know either assist or
replace weapon systems
and this emphasis on cyber warfare and
artificial intelligence tell us how
extremely relevant continues to be the
writing of sun tzu and in particular the
art of war
where concepts like disruption deception
know your enemy win without fight remain
important
ultimately china's powers wrapped up in
how much influence their military and
their economy have
[Music]
but one question still remains
what does china as well as xi jinping
really want
u.s china relations is based on our
understanding of the taiwan issue the
united states keeps the seventh fleet
and other military forces in the area to
preserve the status quo
xi jinping has kind of decided that he
doesn't like this perpetual de facto
independence of taiwan and he wants to
start bringing taiwan back into the fold
the way that the communist party
originally wanted to do that was through
peace reunification so close economic
and cultural ties would convince the
people of taiwan to voluntarily be a
part of the prc
that is not happening
to the last polls only six percent of
the people of taiwan said that they
wanted to be a part of the prc
and so now in mainland china there's
serious discussion about well if we
can't do this peacefully uh domestic
chinese law tells us it's time to do it
by force
the cross-traits relation is a kind of
stable condition under the unstable
situation
unification is the
final puzzle piece for china
china is trying to intimidate taiwan and
the united states as well as other
countries in this region
there is a widespread belief that over
the next 20 to 30 years china will be so
powerful militarily that they will be
able to grab taiwan very easily
this is still a question mark because
regardless of the power of china
regardless of the fact that there is a
huge military gap between china and
taiwan it is extremely difficult for
china to put boots on the ground in
taiwan
and this is because of the complex urban
geography of taiwan
it's because of the few entry points on
the coast of taiwan
taiwan will be able to mobilize a great
amount of military reserves
you will be able to mobilize its
population against an invasion
and so regardless of the power of china
taiwan might be
china's vietnam
you